you might win for like the sexiest voice
ever your voice is so cool thank you
that was my favorite part i never saw it
before
but i was just supposed to say i'm so
sorry for your loss and then i thought i
think i should kiss him you added it
because it's devin sawwa yes i said you
know what i think i'm the supervisor and
so i did and he didn't object and they
left it in because you know oh my gosh
at my age i'm usually not the person
kissing people i love it your
grandchildren you kiss them on their
hands get in there yes junior you're
going to grow up to rule the world i'm
going to toddle off to the graves oh my
god i love that you improvised that yes
that's why i love doing tacky because i
get to be sexy i get to kill people i
guess
i get to do all the fun things oh my god
i love much good thank you so much and
your energy wait do you know jeremy have
you ever met no i haven't even met i
don't think we have but sometimes i
think i've met people because i've seen
them in the movies yeah i'm like it's
jeremy renner yes yes and that's like oh
i don't know him but don't worry i'm not
going to kiss you no no improvising here
on the kelly dog
kill me she might kill him
there's other things you can do with men
besides kids
[Laughter]
tiffany likes this just as much as this
oh my god i love him so much
[Music]
you